so in los angeles george soros funded a
new district attorney called george
gascone and he stopped enforcing laws
against theft what do you think happened
then well theft went up
people are stealing everywhere thieves
walking into jewelry stores and just
robbing them a few days ago thieves
stole three million dollars worth of
jewelry from a single shop in beverly
hills but instead of stopping these
criminals officials in la are telling
residents well just don't wear jewelry
here's the police chief of l.a
there's been a marked increase of armed
robberies involving victims wearing
expensive jewelry and what we're asking
the public to uh to be mindful of is
that with these increases
that if they're going to wear expensive
jewelry or as they are involved in
perhaps driving high-end cars
leaving
leaving
restaurants at taverns and other
locations that to be mindful of their
surrounding that they remain in well-lit
areas
and that they recognize that there are
opportunists that are attempting
to take advantage of them and many times
these individuals are armed with a
firearm
yeah that's it's brazil john phillips
the host of john phillips show he joins
us thanks john thanks so much for coming
in so how is what we just heard
different from a cop saying like there's
a rapist out
don't look hot you know no spandex for
you
because you might get raped you might
incite him he's blaming people for
wearing jewelry in public
yeah well this is their attitude we have
a soros district attorney we have a
mayor who called the cops killers and
then cut their budget we have a board of
supervisors who went to war with our
sheriff alex villanueva and wants to get
rid of men's central jail and the
juvenile hall so even if we arrest
people we have no place to put them
surprise surprise la county looks like
the departures gate over at spirit
airlines
and it's not just in the traditional
high crime areas where all this is going
on it's happening in santa monica it's
happening on melrose it's happening on
la cienega it's happening on beverly
hills and specifically they're saying
they're going after big ticket items
rolex watches luxury cars and just today
on the radio show i had a listener call
in who said that he was robbed at
gunpoint in the parking lot of costco in
marina del rey a very nice part of los
angeles and the thieves didn't take
anything that said kirkland on it they
took his very expensive watch
and this is what we live with and the
cops say well don't wear the watch well
don't drive the fancy car well people
don't move to california to look frumpy
and be late they move here to be
fashionable and be late
but
great line also but whose country is it
you know the people who pay the taxes or
does it belong to homeless drug addicts
and robbers i mean why are we
accommodating them shouldn't the
authorities we pay for get them off the
street
oh no they look at the criminal as the
victim and if you are the victim of a
crime they want you to check your
privilege
they have
everything upside down what is right is
wrong what is wrong is right but that is
what the political establishment here
thinks from top to bottom from the mayor
the district attorney the police chief
down to the city council the whole
county needs a change yeah it's a
punishment regime you're exactly right
that's what equity is they're hurting
you on purpose
john phillips appreciate it thank you
very nicely thank you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight